echte arbeit für echte kerle
das war das versprechen der
industrialisierung in deutschland doch
mit dem kohleausstieg soll das
geschichte sein die politik hat viel
geld für neue jobs versprochen doch vor
ort macht sich ernüchterung breit
wir beobachten moment dass immer mehr
leute immer mehr ministerien auch
klebrige finger bekommen heißt die
versuchen das geld was eigentlich für
diese region hier gedacht ist irgendwo
abzugreifen die menschen sind skeptisch
dass sie auch wirklich am ende wenn ihr
arbeitsplatz ehrenfeld tatsächlich einen
neuen job kommen und es ist auch
berechtigt dabei hat die politik den
menschen in den revieren ein versprechen
gegeben wir wollen erst die neuen
arbeitsplätze und dann den kohle
ausstieg im juli 2020 verabschiedet der
bundestag mit dem kohleausstieg das
struktur stärkung gesetz in höhe von 40
milliarden euro das ziel zitat die
finanzhilfen dienen der sicherung der
beschäftigung im zuge des ausstiegs aus
dem braunkohleabbau
so sehen sie offenbar aus die neuen jobs
brandenburg fördert mit dem geld zum
kohleausstieg an techno festival die
wilde möhre ob ihr bergleute arbeit
finden
nach gut einem jahr kohle geld ist so
mancher euro geflossen nach görlitz 5
millionen für den ausbau des tierparks
nach bischofswerda 16 millionen für ein
kulturhaus 20 millionen gehen nach
hoyerswerda für die sanierung des
lausitz in drebkau erhält das festival
bilde möhre 19 millionen die bühne
senftenberg 6,5 millionen für ein neues
requisiten haus und großschönau
zugegeben ein wenig außerhalb erhält
immerhin noch 800.000 euro für eine
textile kreativwerkstatt
damit können wir gar nichts anfangen bei
uns arbeiten elektriker schlosser
mechatroniker aber auch kaufmännische
berufe und genau so was brauchen wir
wertschöpfung arbeitsplätze industrielle
arbeitsplätze in wildau vor den toren
berlins und etwa eineinhalb autostunden
von der lausitz entfernt gönnt sich die
bundesregierung für das
robert-koch-institut ganz was feines und
fortschrittliches
ein zentrum für künstliche intelligenz
kostenpunkt 310 millionen euro aus dem
strukturfonds gesetz kohlekumpel werden
hier wohl kaum arbeit finden die tinte
war noch nicht mal trocken unter den
jetzigen struktur stärken sie sitzt da
hat man schon angefangen mit dieser
trickserei und die muss aufhören und
dazu gehören einfach dass solche
entscheidungen erst einmal rückgängig
gemacht werden
zuständig für die vergabe der
fördermittel sind die betroffenen
bundesländern brandenburgs
ministerpräsident beute weist den
vorwurf der verschwendung von sich
immerhin die bahn will in der lausitz
künftig die cs reparieren ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass wir schaffen
können fünf bis sechstausend neue
industrie arbeitsplätze in der region in
der lausitzer in der brandenburger
lausitz bis zum ende der 28 29 jahre zu
bekommen und das ist der weg den wir
gehen
alexander linda und tom würden das nur
zu gerne glauben sie haben ihre
ausbildung begonnen bei der leg in der
lausitz doch im kraftwerk sollen schon
bald die lichter ausgehen
wir haben noch ein bisschen zukunft vor
uns dass wir verwenden wir das wort
perspektiven wenn man so gerne weil das
ist einfach das was uns gerade fehlt
spremberg in der lausitz
21.000 menschen leben hier viele von der
kohle die eltern haben es schon einmal
erlebt das blühende landschaften
versprochen wurden und am ende die
massenarbeitslosigkeit kam die leute
hier wissen was es heißt wenn hier alles
wegfällt und wenn ihr dann plötzlich
halt alles von vorne gestartet werden
muss deswegen brauchen wir auf diesen
schnellen wandel und nicht auf diesen
lang weil wir daraus gelernt haben zwar
nicht direkt weil wir ja nicht direkt
mit betroffen waren aber wie ist
natürlich von der alten generation
mitbekommen wie es damals war die neue
regierung hat keine schnellen angebote
aber sie bild schnell abschalten die
grünen machen druck bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen sie wollen den
kohleausstieg um acht jahre vorziehen
bis 2030 wäre ein solcher unlauter
lausitz bier versprochen und avisiert
wurde nicht möglich in so kurzer zeit
geht das nicht wäre eine katastrophe für
die region für die belegschaft aber auch
für die bundesrepublik deutschland
brandenburgs ministerpräsident hatte
noch zwei tage vor der bundestagswahl
ein vorziehen des ausstiegs für
unrealistisch erklärt jetzt sitzt er in
der arbeitsgruppe die genau das
verhandelt die stehen doch eigentlich im
wort
2038 wenn jetzt vorgezogen wird wie
können sie das den leuten in der lausitz
erklären ist der politik noch ich habe
mich immer vor die menschen gestellt ich
komme aus der region ich kenne viele
menschen da und habe entscheidungen
dann auch begründet und mit den menschen
diskutiert vor ort ich werde natürlich
aber wir verhandeln der momentan noch
dann auch mich hinstellen wenn es ein
anderes ergebnis geben sollte hier tief
im westen steht das ende der kohle schon
kurz bevor bedburg im rheinischen revier
bürgermeister solbach hat die hoffnung
eigentlich aufgegeben dass aus dem
struktur stärkung gesetz dass von den 40
milliarden für ihn etwas sinnvolles
abfällt
14 monaten verlieren hier selbst tausend
menschen ihren arbeitsplatz und mein
ziel ist es was wir dann was zählbares
auf dem platz haben und im moment haben
wir das einfach nicht dabei fördert auch
nordrhein-westfalen großzügig für
altenhofen ein neues schul und
sportzentrum ihn denn möchte sein
freizeitzentrum weiterentwickeln in titz
sieht man bedarf für coworking spaces in
elsdorf soll ein food campus entstehen
und erkelenz bot passend dazu eine
kantine der zukunft
auch hier dutzende projekte die eins
gemeinsam haben sie bringen kaum jobs
schon gar nicht für bergarbeiter
hier hat niemand ein verständnis dafür
wenn mit 70 millionen euro in aachen der
volleyball und der reitsport gefördert
wird auch bürgermeister solbach hat
einen antrag gestellt mit der energie
aus dem kommunalen windpark wenn er eine
elektrolyse anlage betreiben so grünen
wasserstoff produzieren und industrie
jobs schaffen doch die mittel aus dem
strukturfonds gesetz gehen vor allem in
forschungsprojekte deshalb dürfte er
dann die anlage nur zu
demonstrationszwecken
bauen wir wollen nichts demonstrieren
sondern wir haben eine anwender basiert
ist ein anwender basierte szenario
entwickelt und wir müssen aber jetzt
wenn wir die fördermittel in anspruch
nehmen wollen eben nach drei jahren vier
jahren nach ende der projektlaufzeit den
elektrolyse abbauen die arbeitsplätze
die geschaffen sind wieder abbauen und
das macht halt überhaupt keinen sinn
die düsseldorfer landesregierung weiß
bei der frage nach der verantwortung
nach berlin und von dort geht der
fingerzeig zurück was wir im moment noch
nicht in der weise an treffen sind
richtlinien auch des bundes zur
schnelleren förderung da sind wir mit
dem bund im austausch also wenn man hier
beschleunigen will dann muss man
sicherlich die richtlinien auch noch
vereinfachen das ist ehrlich gesagt das
gegenteil von strukturförderung wir
brauchen hier effektiv einfach
handhabbare mechanismen und ich habe
kein verständnis dass insbesondere die
landesregierungen die das vor ort
umsetzen sollten das ist deren aufgabe
nach struktur stärkung gesetz das die
das nicht hinbekommen
fazit an die gelder kommt vor allem der
übung im ausfüllen von anträgen hat und
nicht mehr jobs schafft wenn der
kohleausstieg vorgezogen wird dann
könnte auch das festival wilde möhre
früher mit dem geld rechnen
die menschen in der lausitz hätten dann
früher und womöglich bessere musik aber
kaum neue jobs